Adam Sandler actor comedian and his new
film is uncut gems nationwide Christmas
Day yes in New York and Los Angeles the
best next Friday December 13th you can
see it
Sandman won a big award yesterday yes
yes the National Board of Review awarded
him the best actor
they were history thank thank thank you
very much for that Best Actor in history
is that what it is or just this year I
don't know I didn't I didn't look at the
fine print but I'm pretty sure I'm up
there Andre don't you think I'd beat
Humphrey Bogart yes
no he paved the way but I took it to the
next you would you would edge out Zach
Galifianakis yeah maybe not I don't know
he's good yeah but but Bogart is going
down the film also won Best Screenplay
and it's one of the best top 10 movies
of the year judging from your reaction
when you saw it yeah I agree with all so
I'm I'm at the Rock and Roll Hall of
Fame and I I text and lured just to say
hey Sandman I love the movie and he's
with his family on vacation in Florida
and he goes hold on hold on I'm calling
you now I'm in a theater watching a
concert with Tom Hanks hosting from the
garden where all of these artists are
performing and Sandler calls so I have
to step out with my family and then I
just said hey you you were great and
then he wanted a whole synopsis on Danny
Danny tell me what did you like though
my phone call I did like when you're in
the closet and your girlfriend is on the
couch and you're in the same apartment
disgusting no nobody you did it I didn't
okay so let me give the synopsis here of
Sandman yes
charismatic jeweler yeah and kind of a
sleazy jeweler you make a big bet that
could lead to a lot of money or a lot of
trouble yeah it's a precarious high wire
act he has to balance business his face
Emily his girlfriend right and
everything else that comes along with it
that's a lot to do fellas but I did it
okay how do they get you in this movie I
was in
the meyerwitz stories I was going to can
you're right the festival yeah I still
have lights I think it's called the
festival I don't think so the city of
lights
well I'm telling you this man was going
nuts that night very bright Bestival
[Laughter]
meyerwitz stories I'm going to can I
keep getting a call from my agency the
safty Brothers would like to meet you
they're gonna be in can as well I said
who are they and I didn't know who the
safty Brothers they said young guys
they're great filmmakers and I said I'm
alright I don't need to do that they
know what I do and and they were like
now you gotta meet him them telling him
then I said that come on
lately they know what I can do what am i
meeting him by they gave me a movie
something anyways I'm they told me just
watch their movie so when I came back
home from camp too late I didn't see him
in Kent I watched good time did you see
good time yeah oh man so I was like oh
my god great then I just watched all
their movies and everything they did I
was like alright so let's get that
meeting going yeah they did the one with
Robert Pattinson yes yeah it was very
good very good
now did they write the movie with you in
mind I apparently they sent the script
to me 10 years ago and sandy so yeah 10
years ago they bought it so your manager
just didn't give it to you I don't see
everything I can't see everything but
yeah he made the decision not for you
buddy but maybe he was right I was a
little young for it for that movie okay
ten years ago maybe okay but it all
worked out and these guys are good
now you did an audition no no we just
sat in had a bunch of meetings in New
York and we talked about the character I
talked about everything and whatever
what you know it's nerve-racking because
I didn't I was you know naked and crazy
oh yeah there is a scene where there is
nudity yes no no none of the front but
still on
I think I saw a little bit of the profit
might be it hop down for this in the
trunk yeah he gets he gets it gets
roughed up a little bit yeah and he's
naked he gets locked into the trunk of
his car
yeah man and I'm being nude nude is
awful in front of anybody for me I don't
even okay but where what are you wearing
in that scene that what I'm not wearing
anything but I'm in the trunk and they
call action and you shoot it and I'm in
the trunk of a car by llola and then
they call cut and it's done and
everyone's moving on but then you got to
get out of the trunk and you you're
naked and so I'm looking for something
to block myself with it because it's
just it's just awful this is the rear
change and so is there a director's cut
with nudity more nudity maybe they could
be the guys were very nice they saw it
in my eyes please don't do this
I thought you were terrified from the
scene you were terrified what was the
hardest part of this well I'm telling
you what happened was I read the script
and I was terrified and Jackie I said
your wife my wife I had can you read
this and we said and she was like oh my
god it's great and blah blah but I said
I'm terrified to do this but you know
it's like two months of being this guy
and she's like yeah she just calmed me
down and said you can do all this stuff
and commit to it jump in and Baah bah
bah and so we did and now yeah I'm
scared
but fun I I grew to love being the guy
but also you're not in control
Yeah right well because normally you're
in control of your movies right the
comedies he'll it feels good feels good
to just say yeah I felt like you doing
my sets like what else and me know the
guys they knew what they wanted they
knew what this guy was and they'd grew
up going to the 47th Street and and they
just brought me into that world I
learned a lot have you ever bought
jewelry from the diamond I don't think
you have I don't think I was terrifying
why you're afraid I got my engagement
ring there you did yes that's funny I
got locked in a jewelry store right so I
was with my wife we were just looking
and we walked into a store and the guy
locked the door uh-huh
and he said you're not getting out until
you buy an engagement oh and I said no
no let me out let me out let me out let
me out and I was panicked my wife said
open the door open the door help my
future and then I went outside just to
get you know fresh air if you come out
of a jewelry store with no package
everybody else on the street then they
send runners over and say hey come on
over here what are you looking for yeah
right so I had like four different guys
coming over right to go and I said of my
wife I said I got to get out of here
because yes getting engages you know
that's something on private moment yeah
Adam Sandler's joining us uncut gems
nationwide on December 25th it was Kevin
Garnett was the was his seam written
that that character was written with him
in mind I think they wrote at ten years
ago for a Stoudemire and then it was
gonna be in New York it was kamar was
here okay I think cuz he had a nice
connection with mystical stuff and
Israel and Jews and they were Jewish
I'm not sure yeah I think tautomer is
that right in the club yeah him and
Jordan Farmar are all star players oh
yeah yeah that's a great acquisition for
you guys though Sandman yeah that was a
good I mean having stottlemyre that was
big that was right that kid in Memphis -
James Weisman I think no he's not he's
not Jewish
Oh his last Wiseman yeah that my friend
said a great joke that maybe it's an old
joke but spider-man spider-man Jewish
things you have to add like your accent
is yes I was doing doing I met a few
guys there and I was kind of doing a
little taste of all those guys all that
all the guys on the block were helping
us with the movie and I got to follow
them and
a couple guys in particular I was taking
their mannerisms and attitudes and a
little of their voice but also when you
go there's certain places in New York
where you're not going to a store
because what you have where you do your
business you've got to get buzzed in you
got to go through you know yeah
security and office and then you go up
and then you go buzz through and then
hug through again yeah that's yeah and
that could you know any part of what got
you nuts
yes it is but when when you start to
look at this and then you it it's weird
as I watched you I watched you in the
beginning and it was just Adam Sandler
in a movie and then about I don't know a
quarter of the way and I go like I'd
forgot that it was Adam Sandler doing
the move that's cool which is probably
the best compliment I can give you or
you just became this person yeah yeah
what did your wife say when she saw it
oh man she loved it she thought she was
a big part of it so it was kind of like
you know some of the heavy scenes I had
to do and be emotional so I would call
her a lot and say I don't know how to do
this or how to get to this place um you
know how to be emotional I'm not emotion
I don't cry that much I don't I don't
think I ever cried to you all the time
well yeah yeah you told me that yeah
you're good at crying yeah I don't let
it out I cried when the movie ended yeah
you did yeah yeah yeah happy ending but
but I cried because I wasn't in it
that's that's why I cry I didn't cry
because of anything that happened we're
gonna get you to 20 soon I could get you
to 20 honestly I can get to that in four
months yeah look what I got for you I
got I got you a t-shirt and I got it
large no no no my you've been slimming
dark eyed no no it's a loose jacket no
that's great yeah no I'm not slimming
down in fact when I was putting my socks
on I think yesterday I what happening
what is happening cuz I placed so much
basketball yeah why would my body do
this
butBut don't you take care of yourself I
do I try to eat right I eat very good
egg
let every day but when you did the
waterboy yeah I was in shape yeah like
now I'm getting older I don't know what
to do I'm getting up huh
what point we're all just saying four
months ago you were on the basketball
court all over the place I can do that I
just my body's not looking like it
should my shoulders are perfect a very
strong shoulders great tricep muscles
that's great biceps are getting softer
and my and we get to see you I got the
shirt off in a movie yeah I look all
right
oh well yeah like all right yeah no I
better about myself when I saw you with
your shirt off man the socks thing
though the other day you would have felt
great about you it was like this I guess
to lean over like your chest is soft now
I have a softer chest than I used to
have you just have like that was part of
my the greatness of me was this
perfectly chiseled cut down the middle
yeah yes no now it's becoming just one
mound of chest used to be to chest to
chest assist but you can and I it I
think everything I read on this was you
know why doesn't Sandler do more of
these well how the hell is that supposed
to happen how many great scripts are
happening every day you know these guys
that are incredible they gave me an
opportunity and I like doing comedies
too so I can't just throw away my whole
life I know this is your you your money
maker is your comic it's my love why are
you yelling at me
well you brought it up get mad now okay
but you you're getting mad at the
critics on me I'm just echoing what
they're saying I'm sort of talking to
them oh you are yeah okay but you have
like punch-drunk love for her I mean
you've had some of these movies where
people go do that yeah I like what I do
man and I like it a lot and I'm but I
really am no I mean this this is if
other opportunities happen I hope to
work with these guys again but I'm
always amazed when somebody goes oh I
didn't know Sandler could act I said
what why did it take this for you to
understand if Sam
could act or not it's different
different things and they see me in a
different way because they used to my
other movie so I get that it looks
different and then you're doing a
Halloween movie that's they're gonna
that's really shape because you know
actors are always looking for the next
project after they do something
remarkable nominated or I'm doing that
and we're in a Halloween movie Halloween
kid I can't all of a sudden make sure
that the youth of America is enjoying a
Halloween movie and having a good time
and you're great in it by the way can't
wait for you to see it he'll be
Halloween you you want to do any of your
lines you actually said one of your
lines I did you be du Bois you know what
we still laugh at that's my boy
when we're at the prison yeah so the
first take and I've got the dance
they're running camera fritz he's got
his camera pointed towards the wall and
you're there with Andy Samberg Susan
Sarandon is on the other side of the
glass and and we walk in like you're in
a moment where you're going holy bleep
we're we're in this scene right now
there's Susan Sarandon who's won an
Academy Award and and then you you turn
to me and it goes TV's Randall Morgan
and you started laughing and then I I
thought we're really going to do this
here yes TV that's right TVs Randall
Morgan what are you doing here and that
was deep in my character but that's
where I feel like I might have taken
advantage of our friendship because
bringing the DNA because I thought he's
too nice you weren't to 9 I got your
back by bringing Joe Vesey around no
that's where we're equal Joe Joe Vesey
yeah yeah it carries the ball though he
you know ever since you said I carry you
do which is I do maybe if this refs
watch an old NBA they call that exactly
I didn't grow up with the older I grew
up with Harden no you didn't all right
but still your Iverson stock listen is
similar to my style you brought up
Iverson no I brought up you carried the
ball but if I could go lower if I can
bend more I would probably see your
belly it's no it's the back knees hurt
what do you have besides Hubie Halloween
how much do I need I got uncut gems
I got Hubie Halloween coming out in a
year I know you guys always do this
stuff in advance I just need to know
what my schedules gonna do something
this summer we'll get something since I
missed out on the Aniston movie
Jennifer Aniston is that her call no no
no because remember she called me the
sports guy like you introduced me to
these women's sports guy Nicole Kidman
could not see she did not like me she
loved no she didn't have no idea who I
was
Dave Matthews Dave Matthews he liked me
until I spilled beer all over him when I
first met him Danny you'll like Dave you
guys like to drink
boom spill my beer all over do you care
if you get nominated I guess it would be
fun I don't I can't I can't I don't know
what I'm supposed to do with that
because everybody mentions good stuff
and then they say maybe you'll get
nominated or something I can't I can't
imagine that happening but it's fun it
would be certainly would be fun for for
everybody I mean most people are you
okay this is odd but if you do get
nominated yes I'm gonna do air taxi no
no no I'm gonna bring you yeah can I go
with your plus-one I've already promised
Jackie but you know that if I'm going I
can get ten see everyone's go once again
yeah that doesn't help you it does help
me I think it makes me a man of the
people that I would bring you are many
such a mess
that's amazing they're wearing that now
great but but you know are you starting
to take inventory of some of these other
performances by Maxine all I've seen a
lot of great ones yeah that's why I go
high he's slipping by that one like who
you I don't know who's getting who
you're concerned about I gotta tell you
I never not one year have I ever even
realized who's getting nominate until I
watched the thing I go good he got
nominated I don't watch these movies a
lot but I'm watching them because they
do interviews with these guys you know I
like I did a round table so I saw the a
I would you know would a lot of
nominated best support yes yes and he
was very good I'm sure he will he's
incredible in both those and and I you
know what you ever see this did you see
honey boy Shia no but I heard it was oh
my god I heard he was great he's
incredible but would you rather get
nominated for Best Actor or win Best
Supporting Actor ha I'll take the win
man okay give me the damn trophy you
want the hardware all these years you
have any great millions oh I have four
punt pass and kick trophies i won punt
pass and kick your mebiner a new hammer
strike and Oscar yes I have a I have a
gold a silver and two bronze --is I got
worse and worse well wait in New
Hampshire there's not many people though
to compete in the punt panel Kelly like
that there's great day wait you were in
the punt pass and kick come on sir that
Ford or Sunoco or I had a room I
remember Andy Reed remember that video
of Andy Reid where he's like 6-3 to 59
he's 13 yeah and he's and everybody else
is you know like four foot threat kids
right and he was in the punt pack
passing did he win I think he did but I
think he's been the same size since he
was 13
do you remember the rules of that where
you it was you would they'd have a tape
measurer
yeah you had to throw it as far as you
could and then they would deduct if it
was if I hit the line that was perfect
if I wanted to decide they took away as
many
as it was away from the ducted from the
distance yeah anyways my kicks were
hidden tape over lunch we're landing on
tape my pass that was when I was eight
you were good back then yeah throw quite
as far than so it was easy and then the
older I got I guess I was thrown all
over I did not know you had a lot of
trophies like you began I got MTV
People's Choice and those kind of thing
I got a million at us you do I got a
million of those in there like so one
trophy if you have to leave the house
and grab one trophy oh the fire by the
way when we had the fire a few months
ago my wife said what are we gonna grab
I said let's just get at it
yeah I don't think that there you know
you get your daughters out and got the
daughters a dog dog yeah and then we can
and Jackie yeah you know I forget maybe
a couple of nice things I don't remember
well you're not a jewelry guy no nothing
but you wear a whole lot of jewelry in
this movie I look good in it
actually I have a big teeth right fake
teeth couple of earrings magnetic
magnetic earrings that hurt after a
while you guys ever wear a magnetic yeah
I didn't know why I was really like give
me take you know weddings DeNiro would
have gotten his ear pierced that's why
he's gonna get the trophy the irishman
trophy do you know engineer oh very
little I don't know I'm like I know the
you know like Dustin or pitcher when did
you meet the president when did that
French hit I know from I don't know how
we know each other for like 30 years
he's funny as hell you would love it I
thought he was awesome yeah I thought he
was great in that movie when he's out at
the end when he's on the dog food he's
great yep uncut gems opened nationwide
on Christmas Day but in New York and LA
next Friday yeah you can go see it
that's great and I already got gonna see
it fellas in the theater in a theater
yeah that'll be cool it looks good that
looks um the guy who shot and waited
they shot it was Darius is that he did
seven oh he was like a superstar DP he's
one of the best DPS and then
it's it looks awesome yeah there's a
feel to it yeah the way it looks
we're rooting for you I love you young
cute rooting for you I'm rooting for you
always
you're doing good - you look great yeah
yeah and then your son's a stud
I remember one who had a little narrow
body on he's like a he showed up a man
he like he doesn't show up but but I
said a Sandman's gonna be in studio and
then all of a sudden my son decides he's
gonna show goodness grace he met you
already he doesn't care what you have to
say he was one of the best PAS ever on
the set a lot better than Vesey ever was
no she BES he carries the ball no Betsy
Gus and I see does he pushes off he
carries you carry he does his crazy and
one thing where he snakes he does some
weird I know he falls me I fell to the
ground and then he puts his hand shakes
as he walks past is the grossest show in
the video up here Oh
my name is in the man cave he really got
it by the way the man caves tough to
shoot it that because in a roof the roof
doesn't get on your nerves so so I see
that he there's a carry that was a carry
it's a home court advantage that's why I
have the roof like that and that's made
by my line drive shot does work there no
spin line driver hey thanks for coming
thank you it's uncut gems go see if Adam
center ball for more Dan Patrick show
tune in to audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV stream for free on BR live or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]